welcome to this video playing ballpark
ballpark is this an actual name is no
name in there maybe I haven't played him
and he's got three thousand five minutes
game five minute games that's a quite
quite astonishing k Kings Indian who
should be three okay let's play the line
that I'm studied about almost 20 years
ago we aren't getting old when I was
still young and playing the Kings Indian
on a regular basis I had studied this
line against against Bishop e3 and it's
supposed to be a bit better for white
but maybe maybe I can still play it here
night situ not sure yeah what is the
right one against that I don't remember
this one maybe I can go with a six and
b5 here I mean I want to play d5 yeah d
5 but the problem oh wait this between
mmm if i take i think he needs to take
with the pawn yeah okay let's let's do
this break I mean maybe it's not not on
but it's the most principled move what
I'm what I'm trying to say is that it
might be that I get this bag anyway
Bishop f5 maybe it's a direct approach
okay I was originally I fought like this
and simply because on castles I might be
able to check the exchange on III but
this is this this is not this is an
attractive-looking move isn't it just
trying to get the pawn back and if I get
it back then my bishop on just having a
size a really nice piece okay if I take
now and take on g5 there maybe is rook
to e1 hmm hmm yeah but I've got night at
night before theoretically speaking at
least hmm it's this possible might be
formed
yeah it's the Kings Indian it's all
about technically justifying what you're
doing yeah I thought after Queen more I
just go Queen to e7 but I don't know
this looks a bit shaky I admit that yeah
it looks a bit shake him yeah why I need
to do this anyway or not oh wait wait
wait I could play Queen a5 rakhti fire
bishops III why not I tremendous this as
possible I mean I don't like to give up
this this piece but this looks still
better than night before and Queen
somewhere then Queenie 7 that looks
shaky maybe this is possible let's
consider I mean he's got the bishop on
f2 wetzel it's not directly on the dark
squares
if he castles I might even take with the
bishop on c3 Bishop takes pawn takes
Knight takes and I'm walking e to enter
and NT one so i can exchange lots of
stuff yeah come on I need to catch up on
the clock be sure you one maybe man yeah
okay I need to do this should be one
night it took Queenie 20 didn't consider
that move and it immediate at first it
looks a bit dangerous ok move first
think later ok ok ok ok he's attacking
of seven
taking this would be would be quite nice
to be honest get rid of this this piece
but okay I have seven deserve is
something okay Wow tough right really
tough fish appear yeah yeah at the
moment he cannot do that I've Quincy
five or couldn't be sick something like
that Quincy five he should just play
rook to you one I guess
of course I need to I need to develop
yeah it's an exchange and the porn so I
just need to survive that okay I if I
can give this check here and Knight a5
on door okay three check okay let's do
that first
95 he's got a Scotland Bishop e7 and it
will need to probably an extra part at
the end though I come on let's do that
maybe that's a way too simple to
simplify matters I can actually take be
30 that's that's nice that's nice to get
this night on c5 yeah this is a nice
position that's a pawn for no
compensation at all a cavity 7 which is
essential of course okay so i have
actually survived this very nice
let's see not not so sure yet how to win
it still got some activity of course
check hmm jump the student help time
warning try 95 m
check check not at fault ah for I could
have played check I have no time ah what
a shame this was just just too slow
check very disappointing black forfeits
on time yeah yeah I should have I really
should should win here even with 30
seconds so it's um with them no 94 for
example here that's just just very clear
win but 30 seconds is so this is not
it's not easy I just need to find a good
setup of pieces it's um it's a very
clear extra pawn but it's not so easy to
to coordinate stuff with so little time
you just overlooked overlooked simple
things maybe 96 I don't know I mean this
is all keeping keeping a clear edge but
yeah it's just just too little time this
is of course not good we need to do
something else something like rook here
or something yeah it's a 12 seconds now
I was I was just too slow here I think
the position after after this is round
here yes I don't I don't think that this
is enough white I think black should
just win yeah so I returned the pawn
which I think was a good practical
decision but yeah yeah maybe it wasn't
with 40 seconds but yeah I should manage
relief but not quick enough thanks for
watching